diana princesse de galles est morte
tragiquement dans un accident
d'automobile à paris mais maintenant on
sent vraiment plus de tristesse
[Musique]
c'est la compassion qui définit le mieux
cette femme qui toute sa vie s'est
occupée des pauvres et des malades soeur
agnès devient alors mère teresa et
s'installe dans les taudis de la
métropole indienne calcutta monsieur
chrétien est actuellement au lac des
piles avec toute sa famille dans son
chalet ici que les tous les résultats
seront acheminés dans le courant de la
soirée en alberta ça sera réformiste
partout à toi libéraux ils ont tenu 54 %
des voix la dernière élection une
quinzaine de circonscriptions qu'on va
surveiller genre des stationnements
souterrains sont inondés au cours des
prochains jours la ville de winnipeg
continuera à renforcer les digues pour
être fin prêt lorsque le pire de la crue
viendra le drapeau rouge au 5 étoiles de
la république populaire de chine
flotter à nouveau sur la nouvelle région
administrative spéciale comment est ce
que vous envisagez vous l'avenir de hong
kong ici on est habitué à s'exprimer
démocratiquement ce sera pas évident
c'est une terrible tragédie routière qui
a fait plus d'une quarantaine de morts
et au moins cinq blessés graves cet
après-midi un autobus de la compagnie
mercier avec 48 personnes à bord a
basculé dans un ravin sur les deux
chaînes radio canada rdi d'émissions
spéciales se poursuit une bien triste
nouvelle la comédienne marie soleil
tougas a perdu la vie cet après midi
dans l'écrasement d'un appareil cessna
ya aussi une deuxième victime jean
claude est mort en faisant ce qu'il
aimait piloter dans un coin qui les met
en pleine nature sauvage avec celle
qu'il aimait
puisque je fais c'est de conduire une
auto rapidement donc c'est vrai que
c'est un peu surprenant mais ça fait
très chaud quand on veut quelque chose
on vraiment donner le maximum parce que
tout est possible